so harlow we need to settle this for a
second i'm not against
defy at all i actually think it's going
to be super super valuable
again again it's like when roger and i
talk about a digital decentralized
currency ended up being
uh adopted globally super important
thing it's going to happen that's you
know quote unquote the finish line or
the goal or milestone or whatever
it's just how do we get there that's how
i feel about the d5 stuff
d5 and i think part of my issue with how
it's being categorized right now
is the ethereum community thinks that
they have a monopoly on that terminology
right they're using d5 as
a uh synonym for ethereum
and it's not right and it's why i say
things like
bitcoin is the most valuable defy
application
and they all freak out all right what do
you mean whatever decentralized finance
right the core of finance is money
and yeah the most decentralized most
valuable
application that is decentralized is
bitcoin so
it's intellectually dishonest when they
say no it's not
and ultimately what they're saying is
that they're upset
right they don't want d5 to actually be
successful anywhere else other than
ethereum
and so we've made plenty of investments
in companies that are building on top of
ethereum
that support ether that uh use some
version of a decentralized application
or do something right so again don't
listen to what i say just watch what we
do with the money
and we're making investments we
obviously think that there's value there
but i'm not convinced that d5 is an
ethereum
only thing right obviously bitcoin it
proves that
and so what you end up getting is you
end up
getting this um religiousness
about defy that completely ignores
reality and also is intellectually
dishonest when talking about it
and so what i think is going to end up
happening is that is going to be
detrimental
to that entire space what i hope
occurs is that there's enough people who
are rational and who kind of understand
the structural pieces
and that it ends up not actually
mattering right but if you
literally you can go i tweeted the other
day and said bitcoin is the most uh
valuable
uh defy application and literally it was
like a bunch of
eth trolls just being like you're an
idiot you don't know what you're talking
about whatever
like do you understand what the
definition of decentralized finances
are you triggering bitcoiners and these
heads at the same time now
no because i think that i think that
bitcoin people
have this belief that if something came
along
that had more market adoption and had
better core um
kind of aspects to it than bitcoin they
they want to see a digital currency
succeed
right and so i don't think actually that
bitcoiners for the most part
are married to the idea of bitcoin or
nothing
right i just think that they're very
very convinced that bitcoin
is the solution and by the way the
market has validated that
yeah okay on the defy side many of those
people i do not believe
actually are defy or
bust i think that they're ethereum or
bust and i think that's very dangerous
so what would it take to change your
mind that bitcoin
i think that there's three yeah there's
three key things so one is
a self like a very serious
self-inflicted wound in terms of
some sort of bug or something introduced
in the development process of bitcoin
right so no no i'm like i'm like the
other way i'm saying
what do it take to change your mind that
like bitcoin is the only thing you
should focus on and put money into me
meaning what would it take to convince
me to do something else
yeah just to forget all these [ __ ] coins
oh you're saying
what would it take to convince me that
bitcoin is the only thing worth putting
money into
yeah oh i mean look that's what
basically what we do we we hold
no tokens in uh from an investment
standpoint
uh other than bitcoin right the the
actual investments that we make
are uh bitcoin i own nothing other than
bitcoin and so
i thought you were putting money into
default stuff you've been into companies
building
into companies yeah into companies right
so like that that's my whole thesis
uh is bitcoin will be the next global
reserve currency don't know how long it
takes but that's going to happen
and then what actually the value that
accrues
is into the infrastructure right and and
so
it goes back to the same example of like
if you invested in the seed round of
kraken or coinbase or
any of these companies and bought
bitcoin on the same day the equity
investment actually has outperformed
the just holding bitcoin interesting
so when you look at it from that
standpoint it's like okay hold on a
second here
now you can invest in 10 early stage
startups and
nine go to zero and you gotta make sure
you're in the one that actually does
that right so that there's some nuance
to it
but it's just a belief that
infrastructure is
always uh a much um a very valuable kind
of profitable
strategy uh and then bitcoin is going to
be
more valuable in the future than it is
today that's my belief right and so
are other things going to go up of
course like it take
uh ethereum for example right or ether
uh everyone's yelling and screaming
about how it's going up in value so much
well yeah of course because bitcoin is
going to lead in terms of bitcoin
having and the money printing and all
this stuff will move
and then the market although the smaller
market cap assets
will just move more in u.s dollar terms
but i think that
like what it shows is those people are
looking at this from an investment
return perspective
i think that the bitcoin community like
you said they're not going to sell
right then a number of bitcoins that
have not moved in over a year
is like 64 65 percent the highest it's
ever been
they're not going to sell and so it
doesn't matter what the percentage
changes if you're not going to sell
because ultimately what you're doing is
you're denominating how many bitcoin do
i have
i don't hear a lot of people in other
assets in the crypto world talking like
that
right and so it would ultimately ends up
occurring here and i think is very
important
is when you look at a market when things
go down
the the blue chip large market cap
assets
move down the least right and all the
small caps they
you know fall really fast when you then
go into a bull market
the large caps they move the least right
and the small caps explode up in value
it's a market cap thing
and i think that's what we're seeing in
crypto so if you said to me you know
am i surprised that whether i'm not
gonna name some of the other ones but
there's plenty of them that are you know
exploding it's of course because if i
took a million dollars and i put it in
that versus a million dollars in bitcoin
of course i'm gonna move the market much
more of the small cap asset
because it's simply got a smaller market
cap and i think that's what we're seeing
play out again not a bad thing it's just
that if you're a student of history and
understand markets work like
not surprised i think we get a new
all-time high this year
i i could see that i i don't know if
it's going to happen like
you know look the only thing have you
said any sort of uh
anything around price other than
all-time high by the end of this year
no because it's so difficult you know i
was having this conversation with my son
yesterday it was like
like i said look there's people who
think the price can go to
30 50 even a hundred thousand dollars
he's like he's like would you sell some
i said well that's a really tough thing
because
you could sell at 50 and it goes to 100.
so i just don't sell
i just i just know that i'm a bit like
you said
you know what's your percentage i just
need no i need to have as much of it
as i need and then i'll sell it when i
have to sell it
and that's what i'll do because i have
to sell at that point until then
i i won't but i i think we're going to a
new all-time high this year
but i think if it happened i think it
probably happens before
the election which i know sounds soon
but to be honest based on the previous
time we went from
12 to 20k it was pretty easy um but i
think it happens before the u.s election
because i
think i think the stock market has to
stay
at a high value for donald trump which
means yes
and i mean they're negotiating another
stimulus package right
um so i just think there's going to be a
lot more money trillions more printed
before the u.s election
and then i think we'll get a new
all-time high before the election
because of that
and i think people are very aware now i
think the gold price has been very
helpful
because i've been telling people about
the bitcoin price i don't care tell
about the gold price
they understand and then you talked
about bitcoin being digital gold
in terms of where it can go i've got no
idea um
i don't know what like happens to
liquidity so say if bitcoins at like
100k and somebody thinks [ __ ] i've got
one bitcoin i'm 100k and they might want
to sell
i don't know if that people have that
kind of like psychological reaction to
it and therefore
you've got a lot of selling pressure i
don't understand all that stuff
all i do think is i think we get a new
all-time high before the election i
could be wrong
and i think next year is going to be
[ __ ] crazy